il permettait d'authentifier un document
et faisait office de signature au saut
du moyen-âge représentait son
propriétaire à maurepas une exposition
retrace histoire médiévale des yvelines
à travers cet objet symbolique
on a pu récupérer toute la collection
des sauts des yvelines et c'était tout
l'intérêt en fait de cette exposition
c'était pouvoir présenter les sauts des
seigneurs des yvelines et en particulier
de la maison de montfort qui a occupé
une grande partie du territoire local en
a un qui effectivement le premier saute
simon de montfort qui est le sceau du
temps où il était ce qu'on appelle
griller des yvelines c'est lui qui avait
en charge en fait la gestion de la forêt
divine et donc c'est un soc auquel il se
fait représenter non pas comme un
chevalier mais comme finalement un
chasseur un simple chasseur alors qu'il
était déjà seniors
le saut prenait la forme d'un cachet de
cire imprimé par une pièce en métal
accrocher ou document initialement
réservé aux empereurs et au roi le droit
au saut se propage à l'ensemble de la
société médiévale au cours du xiiie
siècle progressivement marchand artisans
et même les paysans acquièrent leur
propre saut c'est aussi la dimension
sociale qu'il faut voir derrière ses
sauts c'est de savoir effectivement dans
quelle mesure finalement on se fait
représenter sous tel ou tel aspect parce
que quelque part c'est de la publicité
aussi d'une certaine manière faut pas se
faire d'illusions et donc c'est
intéressant pour le public de de se
confronter en fait à des images
médiévales qu'on n'a pas forcément
toujours l'habitude de voir installer en
partenariat avec l'association mort pas
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
une vingtaine de ces représentations est
à découvrir à la médiathèque
le phare